[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen Fußball
Bundesliga und mehr gleich von Rudi
Cerne hallo schönen guten Abend das
war's bald mit der Atomkraft in
Deutschland
Energiesicherheit trotz Atomausstieg
laut Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck ist das
gewährleistet es gibt aber auch
Widerspruch
beiden plant erneute Kandidatur der
US-Präsident will 2024 offenbar noch
einmal antreten für eine offizielle
Ankündigung sei es aber noch zu früh
und Abschluss der Ostermärsche tausende
demonstrieren erneut gegen Krieg und
Aufrüstung die Veranstalter ziehen eine
positive Bilanz
[Musik]
nur noch wenige Tage dann ist Schluss
mit Atomkraft in Deutschland am
kommenden Samstag sollen die letzten
drei atomeiler vom Netz gehen für immer
nach Ansicht von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich von
den Grünen aber der Koalitionspartner
FDP ist damit alles andere als glücklich
und hält das Abschalten der AKW für
falsch über die Diskussion berichtet wie
die Herrscher
das Kernkraftwerk Emsland in
Niedersachsen es läuft noch genauso wie
Isa 2 in Bayern und Neckarwestheim in
Baden-Württemberg die drei Atommeiler
gehen Samstag endgültig vom Netz so ist
es politisch beschlossen aber nicht von
jedem politisch so gewollt wir sehen ja
dass ein großer Teil der deutschen
Bevölkerung dafür ist die Kernkraftwerke
jetzt noch befristet weiterlaufen zu
lassen und wir schlagen unseren
Koalitionspartnern eben deshalb vor
zumindest die Kernkraftwerke in einer
Reserve zu behalten ich glaube die
Mehrheit der Deutschen ist dafür aus
ökologischen wie das ökonomischen
Gründen die FDP erhält dafür
Unterstützung von der Union die will
sogar neue Brennstäbe bestellen doch von
SPD und grün kommt eine eindeutige
Absage Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hält
den Ausstieg für unumkehrbar die
Energieversorgungssicherheit in
Deutschland wurde in diesem schwierigen
Winter gewährleistet und wird auch
weiter gewährleistet sein wir setzen mit
dem Atomausstieg um was Union und der
FDP 2011 beschlossen haben beschlossen
war ein Ende 2022 darüber haben sich
grün und f okay aber im vergangenen
Winter so gestritten dass Olaf Scholz
Richtlinienkompetenz anwenden musste
Verlängerung für drei Meiler bis 15
April diesen Jahres am Samstag ist dann
endgültig Schluss der Kanzler hat im
letzten Oktober einen Machtwort
gesprochen und dieses Machtwort gilt
auch weiterhin dass die FDP jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen Lärm macht für ihre
Position das kann ich natürlich
nachvollziehen nichtsdestotrotz wird das
nichts mehr helfen denn die Entscheidung
ist gefallen die letzten drei Meiler
werden also Samstag abgeschaltet die
Debatte über Kernenergie damit aber noch
nicht
US-Präsident Joe Biden ist 80 Jahre alt
und trotzdem will er bei der Wahl 2024
offenbar erneut für die Demokraten ins
Rennen ums Weiße Haus ziehen vor dem
traditionellen ostereierrollen im Garten
des Weisen Weißen Hauses bestätigte
beiden jetzt in einem Fernsehinterview
er habe vor zu kandidieren allerdings
sei noch nicht bereit das offiziell zu
machen
der Kandidat der Demokraten wird
also was beiden deinen lockerer Stimmung
gesagt hat das Pfeifen ja die Spatzen
wenn man so sagen darf schon seit Wochen
von den Dächern hier in den USA ist ein
bis zweimal in der Woche im Land
unterwegs in der Regel und macht Werbung
für seine politischen Initiativen das
ist nichts anderes als Wahlkampf man
merkt ihm an er will unbedingt antreten
und der testet die Stimmung im Land nun
sagt eine große Mehrheit der
demokratischen Wählern das wissen wir
aus den Umfragen dass sie sich auch ein
Generationswechsel wünschen z.B mit der
Gouverneurin von Michigan Gretchen
Widmer dem Verkehrsminister petercic
weniger sagen auch dass es Camilla
Harris vielleicht sein könnte aber
Tatsache ist dass die alle weniger
bekannt weniger erfahren weniger
politischer erfolgreich sind als Joe
Biden oder wirkte irgendwie so als ein
positives Gegenbild zu dem Drama und
Donald Trump und mögliche andere
republikanische Kandidaten und deswegen
sagen auch in den Umfragen eine Mehrheit
der Wähler auf der demokratischen Seite
wenn Joe Biden will dann werden sie ihn
auch unterstützen und solche be
merkungen wie heute tragen auch dazu bei
dass das alles irgendwie so
selbstverständlich selbstverständlich
erscheinen soll dass er im Weißen Haus
bleiben will und auch bleiben soll danke
für diese Einschätzung
mos-bundesstaat Kentucky sind bei einer
Schießerei fünf Menschen getötet worden
acht weitere wurden verletzt darunter
auch zwei Polizisten die Attacke
ereignete sich in einer Bank in der
Stadt Louis will er mutmaßliche Schütze
sei tot teilte die Polizei mit das Motiv
ist bislang unklar die Polizei vermutet
der Täter sei ein Angestellter oder
früherer Angestellter der Bank gewesen
nach Nordirland dort ein dauerhaften
Frieden zu schaffen das war das Ziel des
karfreitagsabkommens vom 10 April 1998
heute vor genau 25 Jahren wurde es in
Belfast unterzeichnet es ist der Beginn
eines neuen Kapitels für die kleine
britische Provinz auf der irischen Insel
der jahrzehntelange Bürgerkrieg zwischen
protestantischen Unionisten den
Vereinigten Königreich verbleiben wollen
und katholischen Nationalisten die eine
Vereinigung mit der Republik Irland
anstreben endete mit dieser Vereinbarung
die Geschwister Butler waren Kinder als
die britische Armee hier im Westen
Belfasts ihren Vater erschoss 51 Jahre
ist das her die fünf Opfer des
sogenannten spring Hill Massakers
wohnten im republikanischen Viertel
Hochburg der IAA
wir mussten schneller wachsen werden ich
war erst 9 wir mussten lernen zu kochen
und sauber zu machen um unsere Mutter zu
helfen sie bliebt mit sechs Kindern
zurück das war ein harter Kampf
die Familien kämpfen immer noch mit
einer neuen Untersuchung gegen die
Behauptung der britischen Armee damals
bewaffnete iaa-kämpfer getötet zu haben
Natascha Butler gehört zur Generation
der Enkel
es ist schmerzhaft dass wir seit 51
Jahren damit leben müssen dass unseren
Angehörigen vorgeworfen wird einer
ungesetzlichen Vereinigung angehört zu
haben und dafür getötet worden
die offenen Fragen neu zu untersuchen
auch das ermöglicht das
Karfreitagsabkommen Frieden seit 25
Jahren im zerrissenen Land nach mehr als
3000 Toten doch Spannungen zwischen
protestantischen und katholischen
Gruppen bleiben am Rande des
traditionellen
Republikaner kommt es heute in
Nordirland zu Ausschreitungen Brandsätze
gegen Polizeifahrzeuge
das nordirische Parlament feiert sich
zum Jubiläum selbst
das Karfreitagsabkommen hat verordnet
dass die ehemals verfeindeten Parteien
hier miteinander regieren müssen doch
das funktioniert kaum die Feier ein
seltenes Zusammentreffen der
Abgeordneten
persönlich denke dass es weder
nachhaltig noch wünschenswert noch fair
ist den Menschen Nordirlands gegenüber
dass dieses Parlament nicht arbeitet
in Belfast beschwören sie dieser Tage
Zusammenhalt morgen reist US-Präsident
beiden nach Belfast zum Jubiläum des
Friedensabkommens
eine propalästinensische Demonstration
am Samstag in Berlin-Neukölln hat
möglicherweise an juristisches Nachspiel
der Staatsschutz ermittelt wegen des
Verdachts der Volksverhetzung weil
mehrfach antisemitische Parolen zu hören
waren diese sind auch auf Aufnahmen zu
hören Hintergrund der Demonstrationen
waren die anhaltenden Spannungen im
Nahen Osten die sich zuletzt erheblich
ausgeweitet hatten
an den traditionellen Ostermärschen
haben auch mal diesen Ostermontag wieder
mehrere tausende Menschen teilgenommen
dabei wurden Verhandlungen und Russland
gefordert aber es gibt auch in der
Friedensbewegung Diskussionen über den
Umgang mit dem Krieg Markus Wolf über
die Demonstration
einen Panzer aus Holz haben sie auf den
Frankfurter Römer gerollt mit einer
Außenministerin die den Krieg
vorantreibt die Ostermärsche in diesem
Jahr geprägt durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine trotz der
Invasion finden viele hier
Waffenlieferungen sein grundsätzlich
falsch die
Leute die glauben dass du mit
militärischer Gewalt irgendwas gelöst
werden kann dieser Meinung bin ich
entschieden nicht ich sag mal wenn kein
Lampen Militär hätte wäre vielleicht
utopisch aber besser die
Friedensbewegung sieht sich im Aufwind
es hätten sich mehr Menschen an den
Demos beteiligt als im vergangenen Jahr
die Rede ist von 120 Aktionen und
einigen tausend Teilnehmern die Bewegung
schon immer heterogen linke
Gewerkschafter NATO Gegner Kuba Fans an
Ostern marschieren sie gemeinsam doch
der Ukraine Krieg hat manche auch zum
Umdenken gebracht die früher selbst
überzeugte Pazifisten waren mir ist
wichtig zu zeigen dass Frieden mitwaffen
möglich ist im Falle der Ukraine klar
ist auch in diesem Jahr haben die
Ostermärsche längst nicht so viele
mobilisiert wie zu Zeiten des Kalten
Kriegs ihre Bedeutung ist laut Experten
massiv zurückgegangen die ostermärchen
sind heute ein sehr kleiner Teil der
Bevölkerung die radikale Forderungen
aufwerfen die keine Mehrheit hinter sich
gewinnen können die Teilnehmer der
Ostermärsche sehen dennoch ein
deutliches Signal an die Bundesregierung
man habe sich sagen sie gegen
fortschreitende Militarisierung und
kriegspopaganda gewährt
ein Bürgerkriegsland Jemen haben
Friedensgespräche begonnen eine
Delegation aus Saudi-Arabien verhandelt
mit den Rebellen
im Jemen tobt seit 2015 ein
Stellvertreterkrieg Iran steht den Huss
ihre bellen nahe die weite Teile des
nordirmens kontrollieren
Saudi-Arabien unterstützt dagegen die
jemenitische Regierung durch den Krieg
hat sich die Lage der Zivilbevölkerung
im Jemen extrem verschlechtert drei
Viertel der Menschen sind nach
unschätzungen auf humanitäre Hilfe
angewiesen davon 11 Millionen Kinder
goline
den saudischen Botschafter was neun
Jahre Wert der Krieg im Jemen nun sitzt
Saudi-Arabien an einem Tisch mit von
Iran unterstützten und aufgerüsteten
Rebellen die es vor kurzem noch
Terroristen nannte und die sich
selbstbewusst geben
wir fordern des vollständige Ende der
Aggression und die Aufhebung der
Blockade gegen uns
Luftschläge Saudi-Arabien intervenierte
im Jemen als die hussi-rebellen 2014
Jemens international anerkannte
Regierung stürzten zuerst ging es
Saudi-Arabien um eine Niederlage der Pro
iranischen Kämpfe dann immer mehr nur
noch um die Sicherung seiner Grenze vor
den husi-angriffen jetzt will es
möglichst schnell raus aus dem Jemen und
sich auf die Entwicklung seines Landes
konzentrieren beobachte sind skeptisch
ob das Ende der saudischen Intervention
nun Frieden bringt
[Applaus]
bei diesen Friedensgesprächen geht es
den saudisch nur um einen Stopp der
Kämpfe mit den Hoodies es gibt aber
keine Anzeichen dass die Hose ihre
bellen nun einen Versöhnungsprozess
eingehen mit den anderen jiminitischen
Kriegsparteien er im Gegenteil
selbst während der Verhandlungen
kämpften die hookies weiter sie
mobilisieren Kämpfer sie beginnen neue
Angriffswellen sie wollen nach wie vor
ganz Jemen einnehmen
der Krieg hat bislang 4 Millionen
jiminiten vertrieben mehr als 150.000
Menschen Leben gekostet und eine der
schwersten humanitären Krisen der Welt
verursacht
auch in diesem Osterwochenende haben
viele Flüchtlinge die gefährliche
Überfahrt über das Mittelmeer Richtung
Italien gewagt allein auf der Insel
Lampedusa kam innerhalb von 24 Stunden
fast 1.000 Schutzsuchende an das
Erstaufnahme Lage der Insel ist damit
stark überfüllt laut Innenministerium in
Rom kam seit Jahresbeginn rund 28.000
Menschen mit boten in Italien an Firma
so viele wie im gleichen Zeitraum
vergangenes Jahr
und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport ja für
Schalke sieht ja gar nicht gut aus Rudi
erneute Niederlage für die Königsblauen
in der Fußball-Bundesliga ist Schalke 04
also jetzt wieder das Schlusslicht der
Tabelle die Gelsenkirchener verloren das
letzte Spiel des 27 Spieltages mit 0:2
bei der TSG Hoffenheim nicht wenige
unter den Schalker Fans werden sich
gefragt haben wie das Spiel wohl
verlaufen wäre wenn Bild das Schuss
nicht auf der Latte und Joschi das
Kopfball nicht am Pfosten gelandet
werden
stattdessen unterläuft Alex Krall nach
22 Minuten ein mustergültiges Eigentor
und schließlich hatte Fährmann beim
ersten Elfmeter von bebu die Torlinie zu
früh verlassen worauf der Togolese den
zweiten versucht zum 2:0 für Hoffenheim
verwandelt die Kraichgauer entfernen
sich damit weiter vom Tabellen Ende
während die Schalker nun gegen Hertha
BSC ein echtes Abstiegs Endspiel vor
Augen haben
ja und im zweiten Abendspiel unterlag
Bochum gegen Stuttgart mit zwei zu drei
Zusammenfassungen von allen Begegnungen
des 27 Spieltags sehen Sie online bei
ZDF heute.de oder in der heute App
Tatjana maria hat das Tennisturnier in
Bogota gewonnen und damit ihren
Vorjahreserfolg wiederholt im Finale
schlug die 35-Jährige Peyton sturns aus
den USA mit sechs zu drei zwei zu sechs
und sechs zu vier es ist der dritte
Titel für Maria die seit 16 Jahren auf
der WTA Tour spielt und im Halbfinale
der Deutschen Eishockey Liga hat
Wolfsburg gegen München mit 3:2 gewonnen
die Grizzlys erzwangen damit ein
entscheidendes Spiel am kommenden
Mittwoch Ingolstadt siegte in Mannheim
mit 2:0 und steht damit als erster
Finalteilnehmer dieser Saison fest
Eishockey spielen auch die deutschen
Frauen bei der WM in Kanada die
Mannschaft setzte sich jetzt mit 13:0
gegen Frankreich durch
ihr erstes Ziel Klassenerhalt haben die
deutschen Eishockey Frauen bei der WM in
Kanada bereits erreicht jetzt geht's ums
Viertelfinale Sieg gegen Frankreich im
dritten Spiel Selena Heider nach 16
Minuten Nikola eisenschmied zu Beginn
des zweiten Drittels und Nina
in der 51 Minute vorne treffen sich ja
im Kasten parierte Torfrau Sandra
Abstreiter 28 Schüsse der Französin
Deutschland jetzt Gruppen zweiter gegen
Ungarn morgen reicht ein Punkt für
Viertelfinale
das war der Sport an Ostermontag danke
schön Rudi und auf dieses Wetter können
Sie sich einstellen das ist im Osten
zunächst regnerisch später dann überall
wächst mit bewölkt mit Schauern oder
kurzen Gewittern aber auch sonnigen
Abschnitten dazu wird ein starker
Westwind 10 bis 15 Grad
Dunja Hayali hat um 21:45 Uhr das heute
journal für Sie bis morgen
[Musik]